hello everyone
and welcome to the talk on turning
science into medicine
part of the modern cell-based assays
virtual symposium
i am lisa from nexon bioscience where we
have a team of experts in the science of
cell counting and cell-based essays
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this is an interactive
event
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you would like during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
i now present our first speaker dr jean
chu
chief technology officer and founder at
nexon bioscience
for a complete biography engine please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
so without any further ado i would like
to kick things off by welcoming our
speaker dr chu
good morning good afternoon today
i'd like to talk about unique image
citrometer
with advanced capabilities for
high-speed
versatile subways assays
when we do cell-based assays we have a
few
options if your cells are grown like
the image upper left
if you do the flow cytometer you
trypsinize your cells
you send them through a stream of liquid
where each cell becomes a dot on your
result
plot sometimes we cannot do that
because biological features cannot be
trypsinilized
sent through the liquid flow we do this
on microscope images are acquired
if we want to quantify them most likely
we are manually doing this
under microscope
image cytometry means to turn cell
images
into numerical data the question is
can we do that by design systems
to directly take cells in a micro title
plate
image in a machine produces our images
apply image analysis software
to quantify the image and
come up with different features
objects apply gating mechanism to
classify them
produce numerical results
the lego imager is one of the such
systems it has five imaging channels
and a special optical design
diving little deeper into what these
designs are
it consists of a high speed scanning
goggle
mirrors large area uniform
illumination light source multiple
auto focusing methods large focal depth
for 1 micron per pixel
image resolution has the option to
select
the scanning resolutions at a different
pixel micro per pixel level
it accommodates many different forms of
tissue cultural
vessels so we
with these designs make it
this a unique system different from
microscope
microscope design and different from a
lot of
images automate the microscope
so what capabilities do these designs
bring us
it brings us auto stitch whole well
cell images at the 1 micron per pixel
you hear me repeating the 1 micron per
pixel
the significant significance is
it allow us to quantify
very small cells
so we don't just want to sell images we
wanted
numerical data and this is provided
by simultaneously image and analyze
so when you finish imaging the 96 well
plate you're also getting your cell
count
a lot of times suspension cells pose a
challenge
for images because they move around
when the plate is moved on the image
so it is very important for us to
be able to scan image suspension cells
so when a 3d spheroid is
presented to the images microscope-based
design requires acquiring a stack of
images then collapse them to come up
with
a single image for quantification there
is no
no need to do it on this imager it just
one image does the job
there are multiple fluorescent channels
gave us
opportunity to quantify sub-population
of cells with different fluorescence
or different combinations of fluorescent
markers
so it is important to have a building
dating software like we do
in flow psychology
so this is a quick summary of various
different well
format and speed performance for them
produced about three years ago since
then their
improvement for all all of it
and it is important to note we don't
just
stitch whole well image for 96
well we also present for 24 well as well
as
six web
next we go into quantification
using uh bright field images
doing it in a label-free manner
so depends on your cell there are
different
image analysis methodologies
on the upper left we provide
cell counting for the cells have
distinct
membrane membranes when the cells grow
in clumps or colonies we
use confluence which is a measure of
areas occupied by the cells as
comparing to the total well area
it is interesting to apply the high
quality bright field image to document
a single cell in a well grow into a
colony
to prove the monoclonality
so when we are doing 3d models we
not only just want to look at 3d uh
tumor as a 3d one sphere we also want to
look for the division or migration of
cells
from the spheroid it is important to do
the quant
quantification as well
so next we go into a little bit of
detail about using this
label-free bright field imaging
technique to quantify t
cell so it is critical to produce the
whole well
image to counter every cell in that well
because
a lot of times especially at a low
concentration
cells are unevenly distributed within
the well
the middle panel shows the different
concentration of cells
number of cells in the well going from
over
100 000 on the left all the way to a few
cells
or less than 100 cells on the right
so as i mentioned many times we don't
just want the images of cells with one
members
the lower panel shows you
the data report from salino directly
in the software you see the number of
cells
as well as the heat map to indicate
the the numerical
number of cells content
so with this we the same plate
can be began the multiple days
the upper right gave you upper left show
you the growth
curve generated for every well over t
cell proliferation essay clearly seeing
certain certain roles have
no proliferation versus otherwise has
a lot more proliferation it is also
important to measure cell size
plot the size distribution for each
for the cell population for each well it
is
utilized for a t-cell activation
screening and in the lower right corner
you see the growth curve and you can
clearly see by plotting the cell
population
of with a larger size per well
we can identify protein x enhance the t
cell activation it is important to
remind
everyone to conduct this measurement we
took 5 minutes per 96 well plate
the same kind of essay can be applied
to look at the immune cell chemotaxis
cells
migrate through a membrane to the bottom
of the
plate easily counted be able to count
load number
gave as much better as this as a dynamic
range same dynamic range is
required for conducting serum
neutralization
assay for in fact all infectivity
detection
for the vaccine as well as the viral
antiviral development low number of
cells
in the united states well without
trypsilization
gave the sensitivity to utilize this for
very low
infectivity measurement
so sometimes we don't look at a single
cell
as the assay readout we look at larger
biological features
this example is looking at the
viral plaque which is a
damage zone caused by a viral infection
on how healthy monolith cells
in this experiment conducted in 24
well plate we count the number of
variables
measure the area and other morphological
features
experiment is used to identify a vaccine
candidate
by schematically doing genetic
modification of the viral genome so you
can imagine there are a lot of plates
gets screened and imagine
how quickly uh scanning
quantifying doing it automatically
is very significant productivity for
that project
so now we switch to fluorescent acids
there are many fluorescent labels
developed for many cell functions
as well as for protein expression
analysis
here i gave a couple examples
to do cell psychoanalysis
for both the suspension and adhering
cells
we can we can
we can fix the cell trips and lines i'm
sorry
fix permeabilize and stain with the
property iodide so the plate is then
imaged
for every well every cell we measure the
fluorescent intensity
plot the dna content with cell
population
alternatively edu or bidu
is used to label the acid phase
cell population it is also
important to note fluorescent proteins
are increasingly used as markers
for gene editing of cells
switch gear to talk a little bit about
cell mediated killing assays
in this case not only we want to plot
the reduction
of tumor cells as indicated by the lower
portion that
is instead of proliferation curve now
it's a killing curve
not only we want to produce that curve
for each well we also want to look at
immune complex formation
using bright field imaging so imager in
this
case can give us both the cell count as
well as
the other morphological features
so there is endless different kind of
biological assays conducted using this
imager some example here are fluorescent
plaques
wound healing quantification severe
viability
this is a beautiful picture what it
really tells us
is many different fluorescent proteins
are utilized as markers as a toolkit
for crispr based gene editing
and in this case a population of cells
are mixed together
we use these models for co-culture
experiment quickly summarize
and um cytometry can be utilized
give us many different cell-based assays
on the left side we just use the brain
field on the right side we use the
fluorescence
but in the middle we combine the
all the different the imaging techniques
to produce
additional assays additional acid
capabilities
some examples here are latest
applications such as organoids
for quantification for 3d cultures
immune cell phenotyping for cardi
development
as well as pure and simple super high
speed
throughput cell counting
we do a lot of cell counting cell
enumeration
and we i talked quite a bit
on the pink portion of this graph
and we enumerate cells in the microtiter
wells
but one other important work we do for
all sorts of measurements is a cell
counting and cell variability
measurement
depicted by the method method
provided on the top portion the the
green portion
we take example out of various different
vessels
during bioprocessing during
[Music]
patient sample preparation we do the
cell
viability measurement and lifestyle
concentration measurement
so latest advancement
is provide a system do this measurement
really fast and really high throughput
so here we are going to count 24 samples
in two minutes so with this
i'll conclude my talk
okay good oh sorry next i'm going to
introduce our
speaker
so hi good afternoon everybody um i just
asked the question can you hear me okay
hopefully you can hear me okay
um so my name is steve reese
i am vice president of the discovery
biology group
astrazeneca and what i'd like to do over
the next 20 minutes or so
is talk to you about some of the work
that we're doing at astrazeneca to
turn science into medicine some of the
challenges that we face
in terms of improving the success of our
discovery portfolio
um the critical role that cell-based
assays and advances in cell-based assay
technology
play in terms of our ability to increase
our success in drug discovery
and i'll also talk about one area of new
activity
the science of functional genomics that
we are now using broadly to identify new
drug targets to bring into our portfolio
as i start the presentation the first
thing i'd like to reflect upon is
we hear a lot about the challenges
facing the pharmaceutical industry we
hear a lot about the ever increasing
cost of the medicines
we hear a lot about the so-called
failure of the pharmaceutical industry
but i'd just like to start maybe with a
couple of very positive comments um
across 2017 2018 and 2019
no less than 150 new medicines were
approved by the fda
150 new medicines that is three of the
most productive years
since fda approvals initiated in the
1940s
and certainly through 2020 we have seen
dramatic
activity across farmer as a consequence
of the covid pandemic
to bring new vaccines and new monoclonal
antibody therapeutics through to
patients
and of course we had the fantastic data
yesterday from pfizer uh from the
initial the initial results from the
phase three clinical study of their
messenger rna vaccine
demonstrating quite remarkable efficacy
in patients
so i think we work in an area of i would
argue
unprecedented success in terms of our
ability to bring medicines to patients
but notwithstanding that um
pharmaceutical discovery remains
incredibly challenging
and remains a science remains an
activity in which much of what we does
fails
and that's really captured in this chart
so this cha in
in this data what we've done is asked
the question
for those projects that have closed
astrazeneca what was the reason for
those projects to close
and we've done this uh in two time
periods 2005 to 2010
and 2012 to 2016. um and we've
asked the question for projects that
closed in discovery so that's prior to
candidate selection
and those projects that failed in phase
two clinical studies
while the data is a little old now i
don't believe the trends have changed
so if we look at the failure in this in
in the early time period
in discovery the primary reasons for
failure were chemistry
we weren't able to identify a small
molecule with the appropriate chemical
properties to deliver a drug candidate
followed by changes in organizational
strategy and some failures for safety
and then as we moved into phase two
clinical studies uh a large number of
projects about a third of projects
failed for safety
two-thirds for efficacy and by efficacy
in a phase two study we mean that the
medicine did not deliver the therapeutic
benefit in the patient that we
hypothesized it would
as we move to the latter time period um
we now move to a situation where in
discovery very few projects
close for any reason other than efficacy
so we're largely able to find a molecule
that we can progress to the clinic
um the number of closures the strategy
is decreased and safety is has largely
been eliminated as a failure in
discovery whilst in phase two
clinical studies again the primary
driver for failure is is efficacy with
very few projects closing for other
reasons
so this failure for efficacy um in both
discovery and
in place to clinical studies in essence
what that translates to is that the
biological hypothesis that led us to
believe that that medicine
would have an effect in those patients
was wrong either that or we selected the
wrong patient population in which to
conduct that phase two study
and hence we recorded a negative result
so to improve our success as we move
forward what is critical is that we're
able to better understand disease
sounds very obvious we need to better
understand disease
such that we can then better understand
targets
drug targets which when we intervene
using a small molecule an antibody or
another therapeutic modality
or more are more likely to give us
efficacy in the clinic
it's worth commenting that over this
time period our overall success in
astrozenica doubled
um in the early time period we had to
start six projects to deliver a drug
candidate
in the latter time period we identify
three projects to deliver a drug
candidate
and we see similar increases in success
in the clinic
so the strategies we're working on in
astrazeneca what are we doing to try and
increase the success of drug discovery
so the first is a fairly fundamental
statement um
how can we improve our understanding of
disease if we truly understood disease
if we truly understood disease processes
we would able to be able to select our
drug targets we would be able to select
our patient populations such that we
could deliver medicines that would
succeed every time
the fact that we don't means that there
are many diseases and of course cns
diseases are a prime example
where we don't understand well enough
the fundamental biology of those
of those diseases so can we
improve success through the discovery of
novel drug targets i'm going to talk
about this at length in this
presentation
there is a huge effort across the
industry to use technologies such as
genetic association of disease
functional genomics and ai methods
to identify novel drug targets that are
related to specific disease or disease
segments
that are more likely to succeed in the
clinic
if we can identify a validated drug
target the next question we ask
ourselves
is can we then deliver a therapeutic
modality to that target
and of course most of the medicines in
the clinic today are either small
molecules or antibodies
the medicines of the 2030s will be small
molecules a whole variety of different
affinity reagents
a variety of nucleotide therapeutics
from messenger rnas to
sirnas and the like to cell therapies to
gene therapies
and we're certainly moving to a
situation where we believe astrazeneca
that every drug target becomes tractable
through deploying the appropriate
therapeutic modality to allow it to
advance to the clinic
can we apply artificial intelligence to
improve success and better understand
disease heterogeneity
can we use ai and chemistry to optimize
our lead molecules
can we use ai to improve clinical trial
design and the answer all of these
questions of course a yes
then how can we better use patient data
to inform discovery
how can we use patient data to help us
design
improved assays within the discovery
phase such that we're identifying
targets and molecules that are more
translatable to disease and how can we
use patient data to better stratify the
patient population
such that we can better deliver
medicines to patients that need them
so a series of huge questions in you
know where i work in discovery i work in
early discovery as i guess to many
people on this call
and much of what we're focused on in
early discovery is how do i how do we
identify new drug targets
how do we validate those drug targets
and how do we then find small molecules
or other therapeutic modalities
that allow us to progress those
molecules to the clinic
and cell-based assays critically
underpin everything that we do
they've always underpinned everything
that we've done um moving back into
the 1960s 50s 40s where the vast amount
while all drug discovery was performed
on tissue slices animal slices in
traditional pharmacology experiments
so we as everybody are deploying
cell-based assays in target discovery
we employ those assays in identification
and need optimization
and we deploy those assays in
translational science
and i would argue we're very much living
in a
a period of revolution in terms of our
ability to
identify and characterize and develop
novel cell-based assays
a statement that that is is absolutely
true is that every scientist
that has worked in drug discovery across
the last probably hundred years
um certainly across the time period of
my career across the last 25 years or so
has worked on cell-based assays that
they believed were translatable to
disease
and more often than not we were wrong
those assays weren't translatable
to disease so how can we develop how can
we create assays that are more
translatable to disease that better
mimic that disease state
such that we're able to improve our
success in the identification of targets
and we're able to improve our success in
the identification of molecules with
activity of those targets
and yeah i describe here four
technologies that by and large did not
exist a decade
or so ago that are now embedded in
discovery and helping us to create
improved cell-based assays
so the first of these of course is stem
cell biology
the ability to generate
to use ips cells uh human embryonic stem
cells
to create cell-based assays that better
mimic
um uh adult human cells and perhaps the
biggest impact of cell stem cell-based
assays on on drug discovery today
has been within the safety arena where
models of cardiotoxicity and
hepatotoxicity
generated using stem cells have been
critical in terms of allowing us to
identify and mitigate
cardiotoxicity about toxicity and other
properties in molecules as they move
through development
over the last few years we've seen
massive advances in omics technologies
so obviously dna sequencing with the
ability to now sequence the genome for
just a few hundred dollars
um transcriptomics proteomics
metabolomics and other omics methods
to create this so-called science of
multiomics
and what multiomics allows us to do is
to take disease
tissue disease tissue from multiple
patients and to take disease tissue in a
longitudinal fashion as disease
progresses
and characterize that tissue at the
molecular level
in terms of the transcriptome the
proteome the metabolome
to understand what disease looks like
and that
with that information we can use that
information to populate
so-called artificial intelligence
knowledge graphs to help identify new
drug targets
but we can use that information to help
us develop better cellular assays in
discovery
that better mimic disease
of course in 2012 we had the discovery
of crispr from
emmanuel charpentier um uh jennifer
dowdner and others which was very
recently recognized with the mobile
nobel prize and over those eight short
years
the ability to use crispr to to create
genetically engineered models of disease
genetically engineered animal models
has again revolutionized every drug
project
um and through the use of crispr we're
able to create isogenic cell lines in
studies in oncology we're able to tag
proteins we're able to introduce
mutations into proteins and of course
delete proteins
and then bringing these technologies
together we now have the ability to
create so-called complex cultures and
gene touched on some of this
so co-cultures organized 3d cultures to
create structures that better mirror
disease
and the vision of course is ultimately
or is this going to work maybe this
slide isn't going to work
ultimately the vision is to so-called
create a human body on a chip
could we use um 3d organoid type systems
microphysiological
culture systems to create a so-called
organ a human body on a chip
where we have a tissue that represents
the human liver the human heart the
human kidney the human brain the human
lung
with artificial blood flowing through
those systems that allow us to
characterize compound efficacy
now that may be many years away that may
still be a very much an aspiration
but i suggest that that aspiration will
become reality sooner than we all think
but in the interim we certainly have the
ability to create improved models of
disease
for specific tissues that we can apply
in drug discovery
so what i'd like to do for the next
three or four slides is just um
talk a little bit more about the work
that we're doing in astrazeneca to
identify and validate the right drug
targets
um we and others uh investing very
heavily at the moment in terms of trying
to understand disease
such that we can identify drug targets
novel drug targets that sit in the
traditionally
undruggable target genome that may allow
us to
develop medicines with improved efficacy
and we're doing that with three
technologies
through the ability to sequence genomes
for as little as a thousand dollars
we have an aspiration in astrazeneca to
sequence the genomes of five hundred
thousand patients
on astrozenica clinical trials to better
understand those mutations
that are associated with disease and
so-called rare variant analysis
such that we can identify those drug
targets which when we're able to modify
and may have efficacy in those disease
states we're complementing that with
investments in artificial intelligence
we have a collaboration with benevolent
ai
which allows us to mine the world's data
in an agnostic fashion
to identify new hypothesis that relates
targets to disease
and internally and through collaboration
we're working with crispr technology
to allow us to run so-called functional
genomic screens
that allow us to sequentially
interrogate the functioning of each and
every gene in the genome on a one by one
basis
and understand the function of those
genes on the biology under study
so functional genomics takes advantage
of the ability of crispr to specifically
delete genes within
human cells to ask the question what is
the relationship
between the function of that gene and
the and the
disease biology uh there are a variety
of different flavors of crispr
um so-called traditional crispr where
we're using crispr just simply
delete the gene of interest um but there
are forms of crispr that have now been
created that allow us to either
inhibit gene expression or activate gene
expression
and what we're able to do in terms of
functional genomic libraries is we can
create
um libraries of crisprs in microtiter
plate format
such that each well contains a guide rna
that is targeted to a specific
gene and we can then screen those guide
rnas exactly as we've always been
screening compounds
to delete each and every gene and the
genome on a one by one by one basis
um key to this science working are
really three things
the first of course is crispr technology
itself which as i say simply did not
exist a few years ago
the second is the availability of
assays that we believe are predictable
of disease there's no point
screening a crispr library or indeed any
other libra being an assay that isn't
translatable to disease
so the creation of highly relevant
disease biology assays which we then
interrogate with crispr to identify
genes that affect the function of those
cells
and then of course the data analysis
algorithms the imaging algorithms that
allow us to extract value from those
experiments
and as with much of what we do we can
only succeed through collaboration
so across astrazeneca over the last say
three years or so
we've developed a comprehensive
functional genomic strategy
in 2020 we will have run around about 80
functional genomic screens
that number will increase next year to
around about 120 functional genomic
screens and these apply across each of
our therapeutic areas so
cardiovascular disease metabolic disease
various lung diseases asthma and copd
through of course to oncology
and in oncology we're running a variety
of functional genomic screens
not simply to identify new targets that
are accountable for
cancer processes but also to identify
new targets that mediate either
sensitization or resistance to our new
medicines
and we do this through partnership so
internally we've set
up a capability to run plate-based
so-called arrayed crisp screens and i'll
touch on this on the next slide
we're collaborating with luke gilbert
and others at the innovative genomics
institute to develop so-called crispr a
and crispr eye
technology and to study the effect of
gene inhibition or gene upregulation
on on dna damage repair processes in
cancer
and we've established a flagship
partnership with cancer research uk in
cambridge
um in the milner institute where we've
created the astrazeneca ciuk center for
functional genomics
um which as we move into 2021
will have the capacity to run 120 pulse
crisper screens a year
and just to touch on the biology around
these two different screening formats
so i've mentioned this a few times so in
a raid crisper screening
uh we're running the you know right
crisper screening we're doing very much
what we've done
in small molecule high throughput
screening for many many years we're
using complex automation we're designing
disease relevant cellular assays
our crispr agents are arrayed in
microtiter plates so as i say each well
contains a
crispr that will delete a specific gene
or a guide rna that will delete a
specific gene
each well contains between four or six
four and six different guide rnas that
delete that gene
um and we're then able to reverse
translate those guide rnas into cells of
interest
the gene is then deleted and then we're
able to examine the effect of that on
cell biology using high content imaging
assays
for pulled crispr screens the paradigm
is a little different here we use
lentiviral libraries to deliver guide
rnas to cells in a pool rather than the
raid in 96 well place
and this paradigm is typically applied
in oncology research
to identify um genes which as i say when
the gene is deleted or the gene is
upregulated
that leads to resistance to a medicine
or at least the cells being sensitized
to that medicine
and if if we run a crispr screen say to
identify
uh genes that lead to resistance to a
medicine like degreaso which is a
medicine that astrazeneca has in the
clinic for lung cancer
we may typically run a screen in as many
as 10 different lung cancer cell lines
we may run that screen against different
concentrations of drug and also
different drugs at the same class
to identify genes that um when deleted
uh lead to an increased sensitization to
degrees so or indeed to resistance to
degrees so
and the way these screens run as i say
we screen in pools of cells those cells
are then seeded into flasks
we look for clones of cells that grow
through
and then we use next generation
sequencing to identify the
deletions that we've introduced into
those cells
and this technology we're finding is
having a huge impact on our portfolio in
terms of bringing new targets into our
portfolio
and as we move into uh next year
we hope we'll be in a position where
between 15 and 20 of our new targets are
identified using this methodology
and as i said several times critical to
this is the development of the
cell-based assays
that we use in these screens and to do
this we're using everything from
embryonic stem cells
all the way through to running screens
in primary cells if we can
and this is just an example of the type
of data that we get with one of these
screens
so what the question we asked ourselves
in this assay was
which genes when deleted lead to loss of
the androgen receptor in a prostate
cancer cell line
many of you will know that most if
a major cause of prostate cancer is um
uh
uncontrolled expression and activation
of the androgen receptor and many of the
medicines in the clinic that have
efficacy in prostate cancer are
so-called anti-androgens
um so the question we asked ourselves
here is can we identify genes which when
deleted
lead to loss of the expression of the
androgen receptor in a high content
imaging assay
leading to the hypothesis if we can then
find some more molecules that inhibit
the proteins encoded by those genes
those are potential new medicines to
treat prostate cancer
so what we have on the chart here is
we've tested around about
10 000 guide rnas on this chart
um the blue dots at the bottom of the
chart is a control guide rna that is
specifically targeted at depleting the
androgen receptor deleting the androgen
receptor
the black dots at the top of the chart
are all of those genes when deleted
have no effect on the level of
expression of the androgen receptor
and the dots that we see in between and
those that are circled in these red
boxes
are genes which when deleted lead to a
loss of expression of the androgen
receptor and hence represent normal drug
targets
and when we're able to identify the same
genes in multiple different um
prostate cancer cell lines this gives us
confidence that those genes
may well be directly related to the
drivers of cancer in those cell lines
so in this particular experiment we
identified 54 genes of interest
those 54 genes went through a range of
further target validation studies to
build confidence
and we've now started one program on one
of these genes
with a view to hopefully developing a
clinical candidate that we will be able
to take forward into prostate cancer
patients
just a couple of slides two or three
slides just to finish off
um i've spoken a lot about target
identification
um the challenge in all of our target
validation target identification
activities is they don't give you a
single gene and say hey this is the gene
that you should prosecute
typically these activities give you
lists of genes the example i showed we
had 54 gene hits
it's not uncommon to get a couple of
hundred gene hits those gene hits then
need to be validated
and we move through a pipeline of
parallel validation of multiple genes
uh the first of which is the process of
in silico validation where we're using
bioinformatics methods
to try and um identify uh
uh what to do two things actually the
first is which to try and identify
information that may exist in the
literature that would support the
disease hypothesis for that gene
but also to better understand the
pathways that those genes sit on
we then move through so-called in vitro
validation where we would look to probe
gene function using a variety
of different methods again in cell-based
assays and typically in these assays
we're moving away from traditional 2d
culture
into more complex cell culture or
organized organoid systems
and then of course in viva validation
using transgenic zebrafish
or transgenic animals
so i've spoken a lot about target
validation in the last couple of minutes
i'll just
talk about another area of huge interest
for us astrazeneca
and this is expanding our drug
modalities to target any biology
as as we're all aware the vast majority
of medicines in the clinic today
are small molecules or monoclonal
antibodies
uh with relatively small numbers of uh
antibody drug conjugates antisense
oligos and maybe a few other
of these types of medicine in the clinic
and certainly 10 years ago
the development portfolios of pretty
much
every big farmer every biotech were
absolutely dominated by small molecules
of
monoclonal antibodies our aspiration in
the aspiration in the field is now to
make every drug target tractable
if we're going to do all of this work to
identify novel drug targets
the probability is that those normal
drug targets will not be
small attractable small molecules they
may not be tractable to monoclonal
antibodies
they may sit in so-called undruggable
target space
and hence we need to be far more
innovative around how we're able to drug
those molecules
and that has led to an explosion in the
types of
drug modality that we are following in
astrozenic and we're following in the
field
everything from the traditional small
molecules and molecular antibodies
into agents like protacs which lead to
the degradation of a target of interest
through a variety of um oligonucleotide
therapies
antisenses modified rnas messenger rnas
oligonucleotide conjugates vaccines of
course
a variety of different protein and
peptide therapeutics all the way through
to cell therapy and crispr
across the astrazeneca portfolio today
we have active programs using each of
these
as the proposed therapeutic modality
with probably half of the modalities
represented on this slide in the clinic
and with the majority of the remainder
likely to enter the clinic as we move
through the next two years
and just to show you one example of of
the type of efficacy that we can see
with these modalities
this is a this is some data where we are
um looking to uh
target our antisense oligonucleotides to
the pancreas
um for a number of indications for a
diabetes indication
and what we've done here is we've taken
a longer nucleotide and
to facilitate a uptake into the pancreas
we've conjugated it to a peptide with
activity at the human glp1 receptor
this is a geo this is a
g-protein-coupled receptor that is
expressed um
within patriarch pancreatic islet cells
if you look at the data in the figure
here
um if we simply take uh the
oligonucleotide in its own
we see about 50 knock down of expression
of the target gene in these cells
if we conjugate the oligonucleotide with
a glp1 peptide
we achieve 905 um 95
knockdown of the target uh target gene
within these cells
and this data just demonstrates just an
example of data on how we're able to
progress some of these new molecules to
the clinic
where delivery often can be a primary
issue
so i will conclude uh
there and really just to make a couple
of concluding comments as i say i think
we
we live in an area of massive innovation
in drug discovery
the technologies that are described on
this slide the technologies that are
available to us as drug discovery
scientists
allow us to generate unprecedented
unprecedented amounts of data and
impress
unprecedented amounts of knowledge
compared to as little as 10 years ago
and really enable us as drug discovery
scientists to better understand disease
and better progress
therapeutic models therapeutic entities
to the clinic
key to this is understanding disease key
to this is the ability
to then create assay systems in the
laboratory
many of which are based on cellular
assays that allow us to identify targets
and
then identify molecules with activity at
those targets and that is certainly a
major area of interest for us as
presenter at the moment
and i think is across the field and with
that i'd like to thank nexelcom for
giving me the opportunity to speak today
thank everybody for listening and i
think i will hand back to lisa for the q
a
thanks steve that was great
very informative presentation so we are
ready to start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have questions you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started we already have
some questions that have come in
how useful our current organ on a chip
models
for example have human liver on a chip
actually caught liver toxicity
of compounds before they go through
animal models
so simple answer yes
we are using liver on the chip models
routinely to do exactly that
we also are able to use a variety of
hepatocyte models in 2d
which will catch the majority of
hepatotoxic molecules before they move
into the clinic
okay this one says great talk dr reese
do you have
do you think antibody drugs or gene
therapies
will be the mainstream in pharmaceutical
industry and the development of small
molecule drugs will step down
now that's an excellent question so i
do not believe there will be a sorry let
me let me start again
across the industry we are seeing a
decrease in the proportion of portfolios
that are small molecule therapeutics
um but i do not believe that we will see
a
the industry moving away from small
molecule therapeutics and the reason for
that
is if you're able to identify a small
molecule with activity at a target
protein
um it is relatively straightforward to
develop such a molecule it's relatively
straightforward to manufacture it and
it's very straightforward to distribute
it to patients
which is not true for most of the
biological medicines that
that are currently in development having
said that though
i do see an increase
in a significant increase actually in
the number of gene and cell therapies
that are moving to the clinic
um i'm especially excited by the
potential of crispr as a medicine
um the first crispr medicines are now in
clinical studies for diseases such as
beta thalassemia
and sickle cell disease and those
medicines are currently ex-vivo gene
therapies
and in those first clinical studies that
the initial patients were effectively
cured of disease
and i'm hugely excited by what crispr
potentially can do as a medical entity
in times to come
maybe more so than traditional gene
therapies um
and also in terms of cell therapy and
particularly oncology cell therapy
i think we are very much at the cusp of
what's being achieved with
um so-called car t therapies most of
those therapies today are so-called
autologous cell therapies where cells
are taken from the patient they're
modified and they're reinfused into the
patient
um with the development of stem cell
technologies with the development of
crispr to then
um modify those cells such that they're
in essence to increase efficacy in the
patient population
and maybe to generate cell therapies
that are so-called uh
sorry i forgot the world but south cell
therapies that we can dose to every
patient
i think we will see a huge huge
explosion of that technology as we move
through the next five to ten years
okay the next question is for steve
again
has astrazeneca been doing work to
create off-the-shelf cell therapies
for example allergenics car t therapies
and if so have current preservation
techniques pose
challenges um
that's a good question that picks up on
what i've just been saying so um
the ability to create allergenate
self-therapies for cancer is something
that we have a huge interest in
but that's very much work that is just
initiating at the moment regarding the
preservation has that caused challenges
um i don't think i'm the best person to
answer that question
but i don't conceptually i don't believe
it should be a challenge
okay this person says i know that the
focus is on the body itself
how can all these gene techniques be
applied to fight against the silent
pandemic of
anabolic resistance
so that's another very good question um
so how's that antibiotic resistant so as
a company
not surprisingly we do very little
anti-infective work or at least we did
very little anti-infected work
pre-covered
um but but the basic technologies i
think
so actually so this morning
coincidentally this morning
i remember the scientific advisory board
for the anti-infective
group at the university of dundee and we
had our annual sab meeting this morning
uh they are using exactly the same
technologies they're using functional
genomic screens they're using crispr
they're using multi-omics they're using
chemical biology methods
to identify new drug targets and
diseases such as charges disease
trapanosomitis and the like so i think
the
the high level answer the question is
that these technologies are equally
applicable
to the ability to discover new
antibiotics to discover new medicines
for
neglected tropical diseases i think the
the challenge in many of those diseases
is
maybe building that expertise within
those in but within those organizations
that
are are developing medicines against
those targets
such that we can see those benefits
so we're getting a lot of really big
picture questions here
quite big picture questions yeah do you
think it will be possible to have
advanced
enough cellular models to test the
efficacy
of drugs that you won't need to test
drugs on animals at all
so that's another very good question and
yes i do well sorry sorry let me
yes i believe that um it will be
possible
well actually i believe it's possible
today to create
cell-based assays that allow you to test
the efficacy of drugs without going into
animals
and i believe we do that routinely for
our cancer medicines
however it is a requirement today that
all medicines are tested in animal
models for toxicity
and that i don't see changing for quite
some time
okay and that's the legal requirement
yeah
do you think that monoclonal antibodies
represent the medicine
of the near future i think monoclonal
antibodies represent the medicine of the
now
um if if you look at the top 10 selling
medicines globally today
um the majority six or seven of them are
monoclonal antibody medicines
i think the challenge in the monoclonal
antibody field is
um the development like everything many
of the monoclonal antibodies in the
clinic today
were identified against very well
validated targets
and also targets that were directly
amenable to that approach i think the
challenge in the antibody field today
is the same as the challenge in the
small molecule field how we then
better validate our targets from
monoclonal antibody approach
and maybe many of these targets like
integral membrane proteins
are that bit more challenging for the
successful generation of a monoclonal
antibody therapeutic
okay next question a crispr screen is
usually done on cell lines and cell
lines are rarely representative of the
tumor
how do you go around multiply cell lines
or attempt screens on primary samples
or validate out of a large set of hits
yeah so today the answer to the question
is multiple cell lines derived from the
same tumor
and look for common genes that are
genes that are common to that particular
tumor type
we and many other others in the field
are beginning to run
like crisp screens in primary cell lines
others are beginning to look in tumors
there's also a number of groups that are
beginning to run uh whole animal
christmas screens
um we are not yet convinced that we
would need to go into more complex
systems
but we are running enough exploratory
experiments to explore whether we need
to do that
okay another crispr question do crispr
screens help identify specific patient
populations
where a drug will or will not work for
example do they inform treatment
recommendations
or the the latter part of the question
is the answer so no today i'm not aware
of crispr screens directly in forming a
treatment
recommendation um
what christmas screens are able to do
as an example what christmas screens can
do we are running christmas screens to
identify
um the likes of clinic the clinical
mutations that are likely to arise to
our medicines
so as an example astrazeneca's
um astrazeneca launched a medicine a few
years ago called tegrisso
which specifically inhibits the tyrosine
790 methionine mutation
in the epidermal growth factor receptor
the primary
resistance mechanism to degrees so is a
mutation of cysteine
cysteine nine six seven i think it is i
may have the number wrong but a cysteine
within the epidermal growth
factor receptor we're able in the
laboratory
to to predict that that is the mutation
that would arise following into greaso
treatment by treating cells with
degreaso
we're now doing that routinely such that
we can predict the clinical mutations
that will arise to our medicines
such that we can then begin to consider
what future medicine we may need to
generate that would um
address that clinical mutation that's
not quite the same experiment as is
described or
as was posed in the question um but i
don't
think that is reading the question again
um identify specific patient populations
where a drug will
or will not work no i don't think crispr
will help there
that is where obviously next generation
sequencing
and the ability to stratify tumors at
the genetic level has had a massive
impact and is impacting today
okay the next question is do you include
sc rna-seq
in your genomics area of development
says many bulk signatures are co-founded
co-founded by averaging
sorry let me just find that question and
read that question
question number three no
no yeah i found it um so no is the
answer today
um we are initiating so single cell rna
sequencing
um is um a technology platform that i
think is very much
in its infancy it's advancing very
rapidly
um we
i'd say for us in astrazeneca today
single cell sequencing is a technology
that we are exploring
rather than being integrated into any
specific project but absolutely take the
point
of the questioner um you know we we do
from our own data and it's obviously
common in the literature um we see you
know very significant differences across
singles
across different cell types uh within a
tissue
when we move into single cell rna
sequencing
okay so the next question uh is also
another big picture question
um it was asked early on uh while you
were presenting and it
is what is the next revolutionary
technology that you believe will turn
science into medicines now that's a very
good question this is a can you predict
the future question
um what is the next revolutionary
technology
um so okay so
so something that we are incredibly
excited about and also others in the
field are incredibly excited about
is the application of artificial
intelligence and machine learning in
chemistry
um and this is probably the area that
excites me
most so using
uh artificial intelligence and chemistry
we're asked two questions
um we asked two questions first first
question is
can we use ai to tell us which molecule
to make next
and then can we use ai to tell us the
best route of synthesis to make that
molecule
and we know that the answers to both of
those questions are yes
what we don't know is whether we can do
that to dramatically shorten
the timelines from from the
identification of initial hit
through to the uh delivery of a drug
candidate
my prediction our prediction is over the
next five years
that we will be able to reduce the
timelines from identification to
candidate selection from the current
three to four years
to maybe less than 12 months through
applying ai in chemistry
and we're also looking applying similar
ai in our antibody optimization it's not
just simply unique to
um small molecule discovery but this
technology will
hopefully dramatically decrease cycle
time in terms of our ability to get
medicines to patients quickly
but also increase success in in through
allowing us to identify
uh molecules deliver clinical candidates
for those projects that might have
failed
okay wow lots of great questions that's
a great question that's probably the
best set of quite
congratulate everybody on the call
that's probably the best set of
questions i've ever been asked in one of
these
presentations yeah a lot a lot of big
thinkers out there today for
for this talk so i would like to thank
you
steve and jean for your presentations
and
i would like to thank everybody for
joining us today for this presentation
we ask that you complete a short survey
at the close of this webinar
your thoughts and comments would be
greatly appreciated especially
from such big thinkers that we have on
here
make sure you visit the poster hall and
exhibit booths where you can learn more
about a variety of exciting technologies
that we have
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through july of 2021
until next time thank you very much and
have a great day